[Música]
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden calificó de brutales los ataques
de Rusia a zonas civiles de Ucrania como
respuesta a la explosión en el puente de
crimea desde el lunes las fuerzas de
Moscú han escalado su ofensiva con más
de 100 lanzamientos de misiles que han
matado a más de 20 personas conectaremos
con Washington
nuevo día de protestas en Irán desatadas
por la muerte de maxammib la joven iraní
que murió bajo custodia de la policía de
la moral el 16 de septiembre su caso ha
desencadenado un movimiento masivo
contra el régimen de la república
islámica
hoy el 12 de octubre se conmemora en
gran parte de América y en España la
llegada de Cristóbal Colón al continente
americano una llegada que dio pie a la
colonización española del continente por
lo que celebrar la fecha es motivo de
malestar entre gran parte de la
población que recuerda el genocidio de
los pueblos indígenas
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relacionada con la guerra en Ucrania
porque Rusia escaló su ofensiva desde el
lunes las fuerzas de Moscú han atacado
el territorio ucraniano con más de 100
misiles que han matado más de 20
personas y han herido a decenas de
civiles el presidente ruso Vladimir
Putin aseguró que los bombardeos son una
respuesta a la explosión del sábado en
el puente de crimea un incidente que el
kremlin calificó de acto de terrorismo
ucraniano en territorio ruso Estados
Unidos ha vuelto a condenar los ataques
rusos dirigidos a la población civil
escuchemos ahora las palabras del
Secretario de Defensa
El ruido de sables nucleares de Putin es
Temerario e irresponsable no esperamos
Ver y escuchar este tipo de de una gran
potencia nuclear eso es muy peligroso y
han escuchado a varios líderes de todo
el mundo enfatizar eso Ustedes deben
saber y yo sé que nos tomamos esto muy
en serio Y esto es algo en lo que
seguimos centrados
y Seguimos observando indicadores
indicaciones y cualquier tipo de
advertencia de que puede haber tomado la
decisión de ir en una dirección
diferente
y precisamente para ampliar sobre las
declaraciones del Secretario de Defensa
de Estados Unidos light Austin vamos
ahora a Washington con nuestro
corresponsal Cristóbal Vázquez Cristóbal
buenas tardes qué más dijo el comandante
en jefe sobre estos bombardeos
Sí el general Mark milley que es el jefe
del Estado Mayor conjunto de Estados
Unidos
calificó estos ataques por parte de
Putin como crímenes de guerra no es la
primera vez que altos oficiales del
pentágono se refieren a las acciones de
Ucrania como crímenes de guerra dijo
textualmente el general Mark milley que
pues Rusia trató de afectar a
infraestructura civil trató de afectar a
los ciudadanos a mujeres a niños a
personas adultas y que esto pues es
simplemente un crimen de guerra estas
declaraciones las hizo en Bruselas en el
marco de una reunión donde más de 50
países están reunidos para tratar de
reunir precisamente más ayuda militar a
Ucrania de Cara a la defensa de estos
avances que hace Vladimir Putin en
Ucrania y Cristóbal el presidente
también reaccionó cuáles fueron sus
palabras
Sí y reaccionó después de que hubiera
dicho que Vladimir Putin calculó mal la
respuesta de Ucrania en en su intento de
Invasión a ese país y David después de
haber dicho también hace unas horas de
que no creía que al fin de cuentas a
Vladimir Putin iba a usar armas
nucleares en su país pues reaccionó
entonces a la salida de la Casa Blanca
en su viaje a Los Ángeles y dijo que era
simplemente brutal y que estaba por
encima de los límites lo que estaba
haciendo Vladimir Putin con estos
recientes ataques en Ucrania donde hasta
el momento se han calculado ya 20
muertos dijo el presidente también en
estos intercambios que ha tenido con los
medios de comunicación que no se quería
referir nuevamente a la respuesta de
Estados Unidos en caso de que Rusia y
Vladimir Putin decidieran usar armas
nucleares precisamente para escalar más
las tensiones en cuanto a este tema y La
retórica en el en el amenaza nuclear que
ya Vladimir Putin ha usado de alguna
manera como herramienta de guerra al
verse arrinconado como lo muestran
reportes de los avances ucranianos en su
territorio
Muchísimas gracias por este reporte
continuaremos informando sobre el tema y
continuamos en Estados Unidos porque en
Nueva York continúa las sesión especial
de la asamblea general de las Naciones
Unidas donde se debate precisamente la
anexión a Rusia de los territorios de
doniz lugans gerson y saporiya
recordemos que la integración de estos
territorios se basa en el resultado de
referendos no reconocidos por la
comunidad internacional en la asamblea
de la ONU se espera para hoy el voto de
la moción de condena las anexiones
y en otras noticias el presidente
estadounidense Joe biden va a reevaluar
la relación de Washington con riat esto
después de que la coalición de Naciones
productoras de petróleo liderada por
Arabia sauditas se haya puesto del lado
de Rusia para recortar la producción y
así Elevar los precios
se reunieron en julio con el presidente
de Estados Unidos Joe biden en un
acercamiento con riad y el príncipe
heredero Mohamed Bin salman esa relación
tiene un sin sabor ahora Washington está
enojado tras la decisión de la semana
pasada del cartel de la OPEP liderados
por Arabia y sus aliados por Rusia la
llamada OPEP más de recortar la
producción de petróleo en dos millones
de barriles diarios en un intento de
aumentar los precios la Casa Blanca dice
ahora que reevaluará los vínculos con
Arabia Saudita a la luz de los recientes
acontecimientos y de las decisiones de
la OPEP más sobre la producción de
petróleo el presidente cree que
deberíamos revisar la relación bilateral
con Arabia Saudita y echar un vistazo
para ver si esa relación está donde
debería estar y que esté sirviendo a
nuestros intereses de seguridad nacional
informa que Arabia Saudita desafió las
advertencias de Estados Unidos real
desestimó a los funcionarios
estadounidenses que dijeron que la
reducción de la producción sería
percibida como una toma de partido por
Rusia en un nuevo golpe a las relaciones
Vladimir Putin que se reunió con el
presidente de los emiratos árabes Unidos
El jeque Mohamed bins sayer al nayan en
San Petersburgo dijo que las acciones de
la OPEP más eran simplemente para crear
estabilidad en el mercado
conozco su posición nuestras acciones
nuestras decisiones no están dirigidas
contra nadie no lo hacemos para crear
problemas a nadie nuestras acciones
están dirigidas a crear estabilidad en
los mercados energéticos mundiales
el desaire de la OPEP aparte de ser
visto como una bofetada diplomática hace
tener un aumento de los precios en las
gasolineras el recorte de la producción
comenzará el mes que viene el aumento de
los precios mundiales de ya está
causando enormes problemas a los
gobiernos y consumidores de todo el
mundo
y en Irán continúan las protestas
desatadas por la muerte de maxa bajo
custodia de la policía de la moral el 16
de septiembre desde entonces la muerte
de la joven de 22 años ha desencadenado
un movimiento masivo contra el régimen
de Teherán y ya son cuatro semanas de
manifestaciones en medio de una
represión mortal así como de cortes de
las comunicaciones y de internet sobre
todo en el kurdistán iraní la región de
origen de masamine amableman con los
detalles por cuarta semana consecutiva
de manifestaciones en Irán
samantats la capital de la provincia de
kurdistán iraní sigue siendo uno de los
escenarios del levantamiento contra el
gobierno la ciudad está sometida a una
represión y a un bloqueo que la deja
prácticamente aislada del resto del
mundo pero estas imágenes verificadas
por la agencia de noticias
dan una idea de la situación
organizaciones defensoras de los
Derechos Humanos expresaron su
preocupación
amnistía internacional está alarmada por
la represión de las protestas en
sanandage en la provincia del kurdistán
Irán culpa a los grupos de oposición
kurdos iraníes asentados en el kurdistán
iraquí
algunos
son agentes del enemigo entonces están
alineados con el enemigo con los mismos
objetivos salen a la calle la revuelta
en Irán comenzó el 16 de septiembre tras
la muerte de una mujer curda masa a mini
después de su detención por la policía
de la moral enterarán la provincia del
curdistán es una región que
históricamente se ha enfrentado a la
República islámica de Irán ahí los
habitantes mayoritariamente Sony es son
regularmente discriminados esta semana
por primera vez desde que comenzaron las
protestas los trabajadores del complejo
petroquímico y de la refinería de salud
en el sur de Irán lanzaron una protesta
en apoyo de los manifestantes es poco
que una huelga de trabajadores se
realice en apoyo de una protesta pública
las huelgas fueron una de las
herramientas que llevaron a la
revolución de 1979 y a la caída del chat
de Irán
vamos ahora a Francia porque el
Sindicato de trabajadores cgt afirmó que
impugnará ante la justicia la decisión
del gobierno de obligar a trabajadores
en huelga a volver a sus puestos de
trabajo en el depósito de la petrolera
Epson Mobile en normandía tras semanas
de escasez causada por los paros tanto
en refinerías de Epson como de total
donde continúan las movilizaciones el
sindicato alega que El Ejecutivo vulnera
así el derecho a la huelga Marta Moya
con los detalles
el gobierno francés ha cumplido sus
amenazas los empleados en huelga de este
depósito de exon Mobile tendrán que
volver al trabajo o enfrentarse a
sanciones penales los enfurece porque se
está violando nuestro derecho a la
huelga desde el principio a nuestro
movimiento ha sido Pacífico obviamente
nosotros el GT en cuanto tengamos estas
demandas presentaremos denuncias a
través de nuestros abogados por el
momento la obligación a trabajar no se
refiere a las actividades de la
refinerías y por tanto a la producción
de combustible
pero el objetivo es permitir el
transporte de la gasolina que ya está
almacenada allí 6 de las siete
refinerías seguían cerradas el miércoles
algunas desde hace más de dos semanas
está previsto que el gobierno realice
otra requisiciones en los próximos días
el impacto este conflicto social se ha
alargado y somos conscientes de ello Es
algo insoportable para demasiado
franceses
algunos de los cuales se les impide ir a
trabajar llevar a sus hijos al colegio
mientras las filas en las gasolineras se
alargan en toda Francia en algunos
departamentos los prefectos dan
prioridad a los vehículos de emergencia
y a los cuidadores una medida que no a
todo el mundo le gusta esta es la
tercera estación de servicio en la que
he estado Así que hemos estado luchando
desde esta mañana desde las 7 de la
mañana estoy en la calle ante la
probabilidad de que continúe la escasez
cada vez más sindicatos de las llamadas
profesiones esenciales exigen un acceso
prioritario
el 12 de octubre de
1492 Cristóbal Colón llegó a América una
llegada que desencadenó en la
colonización española del continente
americano más de 500 años después la
fecha sigue causando controversia por
Cómo debe ser nombrada y por sí
directamente debe o no ser conmemorada
lluís Muñoz nos explica
12 de octubre de 1492 el navegador
italiano Cristóbal Colón llega a América
en una misión para la corona española
ese día la historia cambió para siempre
se empieza entonces a hablar de
descubrimiento de América un hallazgo
desmentido por la llegada de otras
expediciones previas y por los múltiples
pueblos originarios que ya habitaban
530 años después el debate no ha
terminado es el 12 de octubre el día de
la raza y de la hispanidad como se le ha
nombrado tradicionalmente o mejor
cambiarle el nombre a día del encuentro
Entre dos mundos como se le llaman chile
el día de la nación pluricultural en
México el día de la de colonización en
Bolivia O como le llaman también en
Estados Unidos desde el año pasado el
día de los pueblos indígenas
pero Estados Unidos todavía celebra
simultáneamente el Día de la Raza
nomenclatura contra la que desde los
años 60 y hasta la actualidad los
movimientos indígenas hacen activismo
para reescribir la historia en la línea
en los últimos años se han derribado y
vandalizado múltiples estatuas de
colonizadores así fue en Colombia
[Aplausos]
Puerto Rico
y hasta en Miami
para el de colonialismo la
reivindicación es cuestionan la
imposición occidental y colonial que ha
vivido América por siglos lo califican
de genocidio por los millones de
indígenas asesinados
mientras que los más puristas consideran
que es un golpe a la memoria histórica y
creen que celebrar la hispanidad es
también celebrar una identidad común
y cerramos con información espacial la
NASA anunció que el 14 de noviembre
volverá a intentar el lanzamiento de la
misión artemis 1 destinada a llenar el
camino para el regreso de la humanidad a
la luna recordemos que la agencia
estadounidense ha tenido que posponer ya
tres veces la partida de la misión dos
veces por razones técnicas y otra por
causas meteorológicas
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros
[Música]